[Musique]
il
ce paysage allait se régler la côtoyer
toute sa vie la forêt boréale les rives
de la rivière athabasca au fil du temps
cet aîné de la première nation athabasca
super one a vu la nature changer le
niveau de la rivière a baissé pendant
que l'exploitation des sables bitumineux
prenait de l'ampleur
aujourd'hui elle craint les
bouleversements que pourrait apporter un
autre méga projet le site projeté de la
mine frontière est inaccessible par la
route pour s'y rendre il faut emprunter
la voie des airs
au passage nous survolons les immenses
mines de sables bitumineux qui rappelle
les très bonnes années de l'industrie il
faut se rendre à 110 km au nord de fort
mcmurray pour apercevoir l'endroit qui
pourrait accueillir le prochain mega
projet de 20 milliards de dollars
on y découvre territoire parsemé de
conifères de lacq et demi du mid
c'est là où mes parents chassait c'était
notre garde-manger explique alice rig né
le projet frontier serait énorme
292 km carrés deux fois la superficie de
la ville de vancouver
l'entreprise stef wils osseuse aimerait
y extraire à terme 260000 paris pétrole
par jour
un très gros projet dans la mesure où
ils représentent 10% de la production
complète de sables bitumineux en alberta
ces émissions représenteraient
l'équivalent de huit cent soixante dix
mille voitures sur les routes du pays
une commission d'examen fédéral
provincial a jugé que le projet
frontière et dans l'intérêt public en
raison de ses retombées économiques 70
millions
car pour les trois paliers de
gouvernement et la création de milliers
d'emplois
mais elle reconnaît les contrecoups
plantier entraînerait la disparition de
milieux humides et des impacts majeurs
sur les forêts anciennes des caribous et
les bisons usage de ses terres par les
premières nations seraient ainsi
compromise tu mets est saine et gagnent
ce match aux yeux d'ali swing et c'est
un crime contre la nature
elle regrette que les lieder de sa
communauté et choisi de signer une
entente avec le promoteur qui comprend
un partage des bénéfices
ils ne sont pas les seuls la totalité
des 14 communautés autochtones affectées
par le projet se sont aussi entendus
avec le promoteur
cette année des métis de fort mcmurray y
voit une occasion à saisir
willow cas des groupes de l'espoir pour
les jeunes de la communauté du travail
payant est utile il est bien conscient
de l'impact sur l'environnement mais
occupées berluti tu préfères collaborer
avec take rue sol ce qui promet un
projet exemplaire et une réhabilitation
progressive du site
la meilleure façon d'influencer les
décisions c'est de l'intérieur croate
ina
le projet frontier oppose des choix
difficiles dans cette région du nord de
l'alberta
il provoque aussi un débat épineux à
l'échelle nationale le premier ministre
de l'alberta
même la charge rejeté un tel projet
après une décennie de travail sera une
message deux agressions franchement
contre les intérêts économiques
essentielles de l'ouest jason kenny
martèle que l'entreprise a fait ses
devoirs sur le plan environnemental et
des consultations avec les autochtones
il tente de dépeindre la prochaine
décision d'ottawa comme un référendum
sur l'industrie des sables bitumineux
si ce projet là n'est pas acceptée au
dupas par le gouvernement fédéral cet
envoi de message qu' aucune projet sera
acceptée à l'avenir le gouvernement
trudeau fait face à un énorme dilemme
comment réconcilier la mine frontière
avec son objectif d'un canada neutre en
carbone d'ici 2050 les émissions du méga
projet seront prises en compte dans la
décision du cabinet assure le ministre
de l'environnement
comment est-ce que ça peut être
compatible avec les civils de canada est
ce l'occasion de forcer la main de
l'alberta accepté le projet et en
échange exigé de la province des mesures
plus musclées pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques
le ministre semble vouloir envoyer un
message c'est très important pour tous
les provinces et territoires de de fait
de combattre et avoir un plan en théorie
ottawa doit prendre sa décision d'ici la
fin du mois de février
les libéraux peuvent difficilement
échapper aux dommages politiques qu'il
approuve ou rejette frontières le
gouvernement doit se prononcer même si
l'entreprise au final pourrait choisir
d'y renoncer
ses soeurs d'un point de vue économique
on peut vraiment douter de la viabilité
de ce projet là le contexte de
surproduction à l'échelle mondiale reste
le même le prix du baril de pétrole est
toujours trop bas même l'entreprise tech
admet que sa décision d'aller de l'avant
dépendra des conditions du marché
loin des débats économiques et
politiques
alice riegler elle a l'impression que sa
voix ne sera pas entendue malgré tout un
ultime appel à justin trudeau
il incite à rejeter le projet à
respecter ses promesses
le projet frontier confronte de nouveau
le gouvernement ses propres
contradictions
il appelle l'urgent besoin d'une feuille
de route claire pour que le canada
respecte ses cibles climatique